we were already at war
you just couldn't see it because they
were killing us slow
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about some season 6 casting news
for the expanse and do a quick follow up
on my videos from last weekend i got a
ton of comments on those from people who
are worried that a 6 episode season 6
means we're looking at a game of thrones
final season situation i get the
concerns but i'll get into why these two
things aren't the same first for the
casting news deadline reported that
kathleen robertson is set for a key role
in the sixth and final season of the
expanse this was news to me but i did
mention in my teaser breakdown that i
thought there would be new belter
characters to help fill out the free
navy and that's what we have here when i
was reading this article the actor's
face looked so familiar so i went to
imdb and had the embarrassing
realization that i remember her from
beverly hills 90210 what's worse is that
her character debuted in the fourth
season of that show back in a time where
seasons were something like 25 episodes
long so yeah it turns out there was a
time in my life where i watched more
than a hundred episodes of 90210 much
more importantly for the expanse she'll
be playing the role of a belter
character named rosenfeld who in the
books was a member of the voltaire
collective which is a radical faction of
the opa i don't think we've seen them in
the show but he was an early recruit for
the free navy he was pretty important to
their organization and eventually he
became the governor of palestine a
couple things here this is a gender swap
you just heard me referring to the
character as a he but it's also a
whitewash since he was described as
dark-skinned in the books not sure where
the culture warriors come down on
something like that but the other thing
here is that you'll remember that in
season five when pastor was in charge he
actually attacked palestinian which
didn't happen in the book so it'll be
interesting to see how this character
fits into things i went back and looked
at the teaser and you do see her in one
scene in what i think is series station
at first i thought maybe there might be
a situation where they had rosenfeld
takeover series in the books anderson
dawes is the governor there and then
maybe if you can't get jared harris back
which they have said on multiple
occasions that it's tough to get him
because he works so much and palace is
off the table maybe you introduce
rosenfeld as the opa series but then i
noticed in the shot she's wearing what
looks like a flight suit so she might
just be there to represent her faction
and this might just be some kind of
thing where the free navy are coming
together
curious to see how that turns out and
for the record i'm still holding out
hope that we might get some anderson
dawes hopefully we'll get a full trailer
and some more cast announcements and
then get a better idea who's going to be
on marco's side
so yeah if you're feeling stressed about
the short final season there are a
couple of key differences here to keep
in mind when comparing the end of game
of thrones to the end of the expanse
first the writers of the expanse book
series are producers on the tv show and
they're in the writers room they're
actively involved they play a huge role
in adapting their own stories and the
book they're on now the sixth one was
released before the second season of the
show premiered they've known where
they're going since the beginning and
that is completely different than what
happened with game of thrones where they
started out thinking that george rr
martin would stay ahead of them and all
the books would be done by the time the
series got to the end i mentioned in my
previous video that it's not the end of
the entire series we're looking at the
end of the sixth book and they're not
really including anything else and i
pointed out this quote from ty frank
talking about how the end of season six
pays off the story they began in the
beginning of the first season with the
martians earthers and the belters with
everyone fighting for their place in the
solar system with the belters getting
the short end of the stick this does
leave some mystery intact and hopefully
they'll be able to come back and
continue with an adaptation of the three
books that follow where we're at because
those deal more with the gate builders
and the unknown aggressors this is
pretty much the opposite of what game of
thrones did rather than trying to cram
everything in the expanse is concluding
at a natural stopping point so that they
don't have to try to rush and include
everything in a compact but
comprehensive ending i don't think
there's any way that that would have
worked out so i think this is the best
decision tai must have been getting a
lot of comments about the short season
as well because he posted this tweet a
few days ago saying would you rather
have six very expensive very high energy
non-stop awesome episodes of the show or
zero that's a pretty easy question to
answer and without giving away any
spoilers there are some things that
could be huge set pieces in this book i
mentioned in my video about the
comic-con panel that they never said
that they chose six episodes because
that's what they wanted but knowing what
they could do with this i could see
where they might have made a decision to
make less episodes so they could pour
more of the budget into each one that
seems to be in line with what he's
saying here and it's also worth saying
again that they did this before they
adapted the whole third book of the
series into seven episodes in season
three so this isn't a new thing and
literally the only thing that really is
the same is the number of episodes when
you think about these two series
and i could go on the final book in the
series is coming out in a month it's not
a situation where they've lost interest
the idea of a pause and then coming back
is out there and at times they've seemed
optimistic that they'll be interest to
make something happen in the future they
moved a lot of the story forward into
season 5 so it is realistic that what's
left would take less episodes to adapt
and so don't worry or at least hopefully
you can see that it's not the same as
the situation with got of course i was
hoping for a long season i don't want
the series to end but objectively
speaking there's no reason why this
can't be great and there's no reason to
go into it thinking that it's gonna be
terrible stressing yourself out so i
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you're thinking about and what you're
hoping to see please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon